In closing, we covered a lot of ground on operating system structuring. We saw
how the vision of extensible services, which had its roots in the
HYDRA operating system, and the visualization
technology for hardware, that started with IBM
VM/370. How all culminated in the
virtualization technology of today that has now
become mainstream. Data centers around the world are powered by this technology.
All the major IT giants of the day from chip makers, to box makers,
to service providers are all in this game. Processor chips from both Intel
and AMD have started incorporating virtualization
support and hardware that makes it easier
to implement the hypervisor, especially for overcoming architectural
quarks that we discussed in the context of VM were like
full virtualization. Even Xen, which started out with
paravirtualization, has newer version that exploit such
architectural features of the processor architectures to run unmodified
operating systems on top of Xen,
a technique that they call hardware-assisted virtualization.